all right joining me now and I'm
delighted he's with us 2024 Republican
presidential candidate Governor Ron
DeSantis from the great state of Florida
uh Governor um I can't see your shoes
but
are you wearing sneakers like our
current president how's your balance
today Governor how you doing there no no
we're balanced just fine and part of the
reason is that is you know in Florida uh
we're defying the the national uh mood
we're number one in economy education
our crime rates at a 50-year low because
we're basically doing the opposite of
what Joe Biden is doing we've rejected
by edenomics uh and we support our men
and women in law enforcement and we've
done more as a as a coastal state to
help secure our border than Joe Biden
has done as the President of the United
States we've sent people to help in
Texas we've interdicted illegals in the
sea coming into Florida and we've even
helped transport illegal aliens to
places like Martha's Vineyard so we're
getting the job done we're delivering
results
now Governor the latest CBS poll out of
New Hampshire shows that you're in
second albeit a distance second behind
Trump you're a 13 he's at 50 percent uh
similar numbers you have more like 21 I
think in Iowa
how do you go from number two
to number one given Trump's huge lead in
the polls
well Laura this is our time for choosing
we're not going to get a mulligan on the
2024 election we've had three straight
election Cycles in a row where Democrats
have a Playbook to beat Republicans and
if we repeat that same playbook in 24
we're going to lose we're supposed to
have a big red wave in 2022 I thought
your monologue was excellent outlining
the problems but all those problems were
there in November of 2022 Republicans
should have capitalized on that by
winning a huge Red Wave and that did not
happen voters chose Democrats over some
of our candidates except in Florida in
Florida we delivered a historic
re-election Victory and that's because
we delivered on our promises so as you
look forward the time for talking is
over I look at the border situation I
look at the budget situation these are
issues that Republicans have been
talking about for decades and yet they
still persist I'm the only guy running
that can say everything I promise my
voters I've would do I delivered on 100
of the promises so yes I will beat Biden
but even more importantly than that I'm
the guy that will actually deliver a
hundred percent of the results that we
need to turn this country around
but Governor how do you on the economy
for instance you know Trump did preside
over a almost a historic increase in
real median household income for the top
from the beginning of his administration
to right before coven several thousand
dollars for the average family that's a
real track record I know you have a
track record in Florida obviously it's a
phenomenal state but why will you or how
will you deliver better economic results
than the guy who did deliver great
economic results the first time around
well I mean you you kind of just acted
like covet doesn't matter he made the
decision to turn the country over to
Anthony fauci those decisions I think
were were bad uh they were mistaken
decisions but that led to the borrowing
and printing of trillions of dollars
they did 4.2 trillion just in 2020 uh
before Biden even took office of course
Biden added gas to the fire but that is
why people's prices have gone up it's
because of what Washington did to
inflate the currency
but here's the thing about this Laura
but he says he says that he did
everything right he said he wouldn't do
anything different uh in Florida you
know we were listening to them and then
after a few weeks I'm like this is not
right and we went in our own Direction
our median income is still going up even
through covid uh because we chose
Freedom over faucism so I think our
economic track record where we've
actually paid down almost 25 percent of
our state's debt since I've been
Governor we've run big budget surpluses
done big tax cuts and have the number
one state for new business formations
that's the track record we need uh to
bring to Washington and I'll be able to
get the job done
well if you if you were on stage with
President Trump if he was at the debate
how would you go at him because you know
I understand what you're saying about
fauci I mean I was one of the biggest
fouchy detractors and the spring I think
before when you were still you still
still have the state shut down uh in
Florida I was hitting fouchy every day I
agree with your assessment on that but
it hasn't bridged that gap for you on on
the national polls or even in the state
polls as as maybe powerful as it is so
Donald Trump's standing next to you on
that stage imagine he was
how would you go go Adam in order to
kind of again shrink that Gap from two
to one
well I think it's interesting and he's
not willing to stand on that stage I
think he owes it to all the voters to
show up defend his record articulate
what he would do uh going forward what
he might do differently and he's not
willing to do that how would you voters
have a right to hear from all the
candidates well he's been willing to
step up and do it um well he should step
up to the plate and then we'll do it I
mean I think we can talk about a lot of
the things he's running in 2024 on a lot
of the same promises he ran on in 2016
and didn't deliver on he said he was
going to drain the swamp they didn't
drain the swamp at all he still defends
hiring Christopher Ray he didn't fire
Ray he didn't fire fauci he said Mexico
was going to pay for the border wall
that didn't happen they started the wall
but we've got a lot more to be able to
do to finish the wall he said he was
going to eliminate the national debt
they added almost eight trillion dollars
to the debt in four years and then
remember he promised to point a special
counsel for Hillary Clinton then after
the election two weeks later he's like
oh no forget about it that's what you
say before the election is that what you
say after so now he's saying he's going
to do one for Biden but he had promised
to do that for you uh in in 2016. so I
think it's about you got to deliver on
these things if we do the same thing and
we don't deliver on a hundred percent uh
we're not going to turn the country
around Now's the Time to deliver results
yeah we're going to be at Reagan's
Library he said it was a time for
choosing it was our rendezvous with
Destiny I think this election is for Our
Generation because we're in danger of
leaving to our kids and grandkids in
America that's less free uh and less
prosperous than the one we inherited
and Governor really quickly the the
person who's closest to you right now in
most of the polls is Nikki Haley
um from South Carolina of course former
Governor there former ambassador to the
U.N uh she's more of a you know she's
more of a bush or republican I think and
people like John Danforth Mitt Romney
say the Republican party has to go back
to that Republican party not the
populist party that you and Vivek and
and Trump uh really represent which is
about 84 of the of the electorate right
now if the polls are accurate but how do
you respond to the Cheney crowd
well look I think corporatism is a dead
end for Republicans I mean part of it is
because you know who are you for are you
for people that are working hard every
day are you for some of the fat cats
it's not a good place to be in
politically but also as a matter of
policy uh that's a perversion of free
market principles we've seen
corporations go very woke and you know
Nikki attacked me uh for standing up for
the kids of Florida and she sided with
Disney when we had the big fight over
parents rights and education we took the
position that you shouldn't sexualize
curriculum in elementary school Disney
fought us they tried to stop the bill
then they tried to get the bill repealed
afterwards and we stood strong against
the most powerful company in our state I
think she's indicated she would have
bent the knee in that situation and I
think that's been more indicative of her
approach but that approach is a dead end
and guess what Laura I took all the
Flack from the media for so long and
here we are our kids are protected
Disney doesn't have any more special tax
breaks and we're just humming along
doing great it shows you if you're
willing to stand strong and hold your
ground you can win these fights I'll be
the only guy on that stage tomorrow
night who's actually dug in fought these
big fights and delivered big victories
and uh Governor are you um are you
scared that um we have of course Gavin
newsom's going to be in the audience
he's going to be at the debate I guess
getting ready for your debate with him
moderated by my my colleague Sean
Hannity was that making you nervous
I think it's great I mean look uh
California is a symptom of American
decline Florida shows the pathway for
American Revival let's have that debate
I can tell you Laura I know that we're
winning between the two states because I
have so many California license plates
showing up in my state that never
happened when I was a kid growing up and
now all of a sudden we see them and you
know we're down in Southern California
now for the debate I can tell you as
someone who did Navy Duty in Coronado
some of the best weather in the world uh
it's a great place to be but they've
done so poorly on policy the
homelessness the crime the taxes the
woke ideology the lockdowns uh that uh
people are fleeing
all right Governor we look forward to
tomorrow night we look forward to your
debate with Newsome as well thank you so
much for joining us hey Sean Hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to Fox
News YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else